[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans sion par
les sports c'est le quatrième numéro de
cette saison sur tv à 78 au programme
comme toujours une dose de bonne humeur
des analyses sportives et surtout des
coups de gueule et des à débat nos
chroniques nos chroniqueurs sont avec
lui sur ce plateau présentation en
musique on commence à ma droite c'est un
pistard c'est notre consultant cyclisme
il connaît tout sur tout sur ce sport il
aime être au plus prêt à de l'action ils
étaient notamment présents sur les
championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste velours national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'était en
2015 on le surnomme le capitaine
gagneriez tous avec lui pendant 8 à l
quand allez-vous super le
dragon que de souvenirs et bien des très
bons souvenirs et hâte
d'être à l'année prochaine en 2022 avec
les mêmes championnats du monde à saint
quentin et on espère revivre les mêmes
émotions
on espère également beaucoup de
médailles hier pour les français on
continue notre tour de table musique il
fait partie du top 3 des meilleurs
journalistes sportifs de l'histoire de
la télévision derrière nelson monfort et
grégoire margotton il connaît tout sur
tout on le surnomme l'italiana lover
grégory canal et journaliste chez tv 78
pendant une heure bonjour michael
bonjour à tous alors j'ai parlé de top 3
vous êtes à quelle place oh non je suis
encore encore loin du top 3 de ce qui se
fait de lui mais pourquoi pas un jour
espérer être le plus grand journal
sportif français on espère devant nelson
monfort ouais c'est moyen de l'iphone
ont continué à droite musique il adore
les bonnes choses de la vie mais surtout
le rugby c'est sa passion il adore
également apporter sa science sur ce
plateau lors de cette émission on le
surnomme le gladiateur pierre chevalier
du rugby-club de versailles est avec
nous quand allez-vous pierre formé
bonheur salut à tous pleine forme avec
cet automne qui se pointe qui pointe le
bout de son nez mais bon encore beaucoup
d'actualités sportives a commenté donc
tout va bien le rugby ça va bien le bi
sanaa très bien au rugby on a bien
démarré on termine à ma gauche musique
c'est le michael jordan des chroniqueurs
le sébastien chabal de la répartie le
tiger woods des punchline mesdames et
messieurs je demande le silence sur ce
bateau genlis ex-coach de plaisir de tvq
prochain michael retour à tous comment
allez-vous toujours plate forme toujours
douloureux impeccable le tiger woods de
la punchline c'est un peu vous le tiger
woods à une époque peut-être oui puisque
à une époque j'étais debout comme comme
j j'étais là j'ai un petit peu qu'on
veuille lui quand même je suis capable
de faire 18 trous et puis après référent
gaulle
jean carton jaune dès la mission
commence très fort une image insolite
pour commencer le président de la
république emmanuel macron est venu
jouer au football le 14 octobre dernier
sur la pelouse de poids s'il a participé
à un match avec le variétés club de
france face au centre hospitalier
intercommunal de poissy saint germain il
a réalisé quelques crochets il a même
marqué un but sur penalty devant les
1500 spectateurs présents au stade il a
joué une grande partie du match on
écoute les réactions micro de tv 78 je
vous rappelle qu'en 2017 président macro
est venu avec son équipe de sécurité
faire un match contre le mans en équipe
de l'om et ça s'était bien passé le
président est quelqu'un qui lâche pas la
faire sur le terrain comme on dit et
donc ce soir c'était plus simple pour
moi de jouer avec il avait l'air très
content de jouer avec nous donc quand
tout le monde trouve son plaisir dans un
match ça fait une bonne équipe il est
très très heureux d'être là c'est une
porte de sortie par rapport à son métier
entre guillemets de résidents de la
république c'est la première fois bien
sûr qu'un président de la république en
activité et fait un match de football
le variété s'est imposée est 6 à 1 face
aux chips l'ensemble des bénéfices
seront reversés à la fondation des
hôpitaux présidée depuis 2019 par
brigitte macron la question sur ce thème
votre votre avis tout simplement sur la
venue du président de la république à
pau site son match de football juste le
chiffre sont précise quand même que
c'est le centre interne hospitalier
intercommunal de poissy cinq heures mais
voilà même s'il avait une couleur jaune
une couleur de chips et qu' ils sont à
deux chiffres voilà ils sont inclinés
largement voilà c'est le chips alors des
droits qui ce que vous en pensez c'est
via l'impôt si c'est moi je trouve ça
plutôt anecdotique après c'est vrai que
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
qu'un président en exercice vient faire
un match de football
la chose un peu plus regrettable c'est
vous qui avait été présent sur place
devaient pas tu pue trop accéder au
stade y avait une zone ça a été très
compliqué et elle a pas eu d'ailleurs en
interview et après sur le match non
c'est une image sympa plutôt anecdotique
mais une image sympathique qui oui
rapproche peut-être le président des
français mais on n'est pas il faut il
faut rappeler aussi qu'on est à un an de
cette élection présidentielle donc déjà
ça joue sur les terrains c'est le cas de
le dire à poissy genre qui vous en
pensez de ce billet mais je crois que
grégory viennent de le dire on est
proche des élections
présidentielles de mai 2022 homme bon un
petit coup de pub ça fait jamais de mal
le football ce sport populaire en +100
populaire ça ça passe bien mais quand on
l'a vu l'assaut sur les images avec son
petit short program le maillot peu par
dessus on aurait dit un petit pingouin
c'était sûr pour voir l'image mais
c'était un petit peu
sinon c'est pas drôle en fait tout un
plat c'est un peu con les footballeurs
l'anneau dernier numéro c'est parce que
c'est le président public alors mais
c'est normal quand même yann que vous en
pensez vous je pense que c'est de la
communication un peu à la obama qui qui
était quand même un président sportif
qui qui avait des images de basketteur
et cetera bon c'était setteuse a
l'habitude de tirer avait l'habitude de
faire ce genre de ce genre de choses
maintenant
moi j'ai rien contre par contre fin
ce que j'ai apprécié parce que j'ai
regardé la veille avait un autre match
joué à marseille qui était aussi
télévisée
d'ailleurs avec quelques joueurs qui ont
joué le lendemain à possible mais du
coup on se rend bien compte de la
différence de vitesse entre un match de
ligue 1 un match de ligue des champions
et un match d'amateurs et ça permet de
comprendre pourquoi là toute la
difficulté du sport du sport pro donc
donc sage et je trouve ça assez sympa de
voir que les mecs une fois que parce que
même le même à marseille avait encore
des joueurs qui étaient en activité et
on voit bien que les intensités sont pas
les mêmes et donc donc voilà maintenant
un amateur bah oui bien sûr c'est un
amateur de foot mais si je suis sur un
terrain de foot je suis aussi un amateur
de foot donc il n'ya pas de n'ai pas de
problème avec ça et puis aujourd'hui en
france son sens de moteur et en france
on est on est de toute façon très
nombreux à être amateur de foot on est
10 millions de sélectionneurs mais
je suis partagé je suis partagé entre le
gros coup de com' politique comme comme
l'évoqué greg et le la mise en avant du
sport d'une manière générale on a eu on
a souvent eu des présidents sportifs
notamment parmi les derniers quand on
remonte au début de la vème république
c'était plutôt c'était plutôt à la
churchill de nos sports ce donc avec un
un de gaulle et pompidou qui fumait
comme des pompiers s'est pas beaucoup de
sport à la fin notamment quand on voit
sarkozy qui faisait beaucoup beaucoup de
vélo et qui court qui courait à pied
c'est ça commençait à être un petit peu
médiatisé je pense que à partir de ces
années là on est arrivé dans le dans la
popularisation de la vie politique et
donc justement de la peopolisation de la
vie politique et donc soit un grand coup
de com à quelques mois de la part de la
présidentielle 2022 auquel cas je pense
que c'est assez efficace et c'est assez
assez bien fait la promotion de la
promotion de notre sport dans tous les
cas je pense qu'il faut il faut en tirer
profit therrien président qui est qui
qui met les crampons qui habituellement
est sapé comme un pingouin avec sa
redingote et autres et qu'il a
maintenant et en étant au maillot de
maillots de foot short un peu a
effectivement
c'est toujours bon à prendre pour la
promotion d'un sport populaire et pour
la promotion du sport en général sur les
sur les retours les retours qu'on voit
là jusqu'à maintenant ça plutôt été bien
perçu même si même si évidemment c'est
orienté mais mais ça reste un président
en exercice qui met les crampons et qui
va sur un terrain de football il ya
quand même à quelques mois de l'élection
bien sûr si on imagine macron qui se
hisse rythme en attaque la parole
c'est une symbolique avec
en termes de penalty bon il est pas
forcément sa spécialité je passe
commande à lille au football mais c'est
pas ça tu as les qualités le meeddat
être justement de revenir par contre le
gardien il est sûr que l'on va avoir la
terrain l'un des volontaires ce
qui va se voit très bien grégory vous
êtes gamin de huit ou vous est ce que
vous pensez qu'il allait cesser direct
sur un meilleur angle parce qu'on
n'avait pas les droits pour diffuser ce
match vous avez pu faire quelques quand
on a l'impression que le gardien était
bien parti et au dernier moment se dit
danser le président je vais la laisser
passer quand même sa possession il est
dessus j'ai l'impression qu'il peut la
sortir et bruit vous êtes gardien de but
et joueur josas est ce que vous l'auriez
laisser passer ah ben je sais pas je
sais pas vous non je pense que je
l'aurais arrêté je n'aime pas perdre et
dit kurt yves et voilà c'est ça mais
j'ajoute fois par mois il ya eu quelques
consignes autour de ce match notamment
taclé le président et les s'approcher
trop près de lui mais je voulais juste
ajouter sur le côté positif parce qu'on
retient cette taxe de communication j'ai
dit un an effective on sait à quelques
mois on est déjà en octobre bientôt même
en novembre et c'est présidentielle qui
va arriver mais il y avait aussi un an
caritatif c'était pour la fondation des
hôpitaux qui est présidée par l'épousé
la première dame de france brigitte
macron donc il ya aussi ce côté positif
c'est effectivement un coup de com ça
met en avant le football mais ça met en
avant aussi cet acquis cette action
caritative alors nous allons maintenant
passer au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler football
évidemment les viennois habib beye vient
d'être nommé entraîneur du red star coup
de projecteur sur arthur wint neige le
tennisman l'illinois vient d'être appelé
pour participer à la coupe davis mais
avant de développer on va parler
cyclisme
[Musique]
on va donc parler à cyclisme dans ce
associant par les sports le parcours du
tour de france 2022 vient d'être
dévoilée et très grosse surprise la
dernière étape du tour de france ne
partira pas des yvelines alors qu'une
convention a été signée entre les
organisateurs aso le département
jusqu'en 2023 les rumeurs évoquées le
zoo de thoiry c'était quasiment certain
selon certains médias mais finalement le
peloton partira de la défense dans les
hauts-de-seine joint par téléphone le
département des yvelines aurait validé
ce choix le zoo de thoiry annoncé de son
côté une feuille news le peloton devrait
quand même passer par les éminents 2022
et le départ en 2023 devrait se faire au
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la question
sur ce thème est ce que c'est un
véritable coup de théâtre oui ou non
vous votez
oui oui vous êtes tous unanimes
grégory je serai j'amènerai juste des
d'ores et déjà peut-être un élément de
réflexion effectivement il ya une
convention ça vous l'avez rappelé qui a
été signé avec le département pour que
le tour passe par les yvelines jusqu'en
2023 on évoque effectivement se déporte
du vélodrome de saint quentin à un an à
des jo qui se dérouleront en france donc
la symbolique était tout trouvé
maintenant je me suis replongé dans nos
archives et effectivement le reportage
qu on avait dit qu'on avait dont on
avait consacré à l'époque parlait bien
de passer passera par le par le
département des yvelines jusqu'en 2023
et ce que est ce que cette petite
différence de passera ou partira à jouer
peut-être dans la convention je ne sais
pas il faudrait qu'on se replongeant là
dans la convention maintenant ce qui est
sûr c'est que c'est effectivement
étonnant même le département à l'époque
voilà étaient étaient très fiers
d'accueillir ce départ du tour de france
il ya les villes commentait de la jolie
où ils chatouillent dans ces dernières
années chaque année il ya également
qu'ils ont accueilli donc c'est vrai
qu'on peut s'en étonner maintenant
est-ce que effectivement le département
des yvelines n'a pas voulu mettre en
avant son rapprochement avec les
hauts-de-seine qui interviennent depuis
2016 c'est aussi c'est aussi une
question maintenant c'est sûr que c'est
un coup de théâtre puisque tout le monde
annonçait touahri en général les médias
quand il annonce le départ d'une ville
il serait apparemment c'est pour ça que
c'était par exemple les journalistes
avait dit touahri c'est sûr à 99% en pas
encore l'officialisation mais c'est sûr
à 99% et finalement le seul endroit où
sanaa où ils se sont trompés c'est le
zoo de thoiry
me vous y étiez la rotation et donc je
discutais avec avant avant la possible
augmentation geste d'émettre une tour
par de thoiry en plus je l'avais entendu
le matin en allant en avant la
présentation et grande surprise départ
de la défense eut arena
alors oui le parcours passe bien par les
yvelines en effet il y aura une grosse
partie d'étape qui sera dans les
yvelines mais sûrement le nord des îles
dit oui oui bah tu as en passant de la
défense on peut difficilement aller on
peut difficilement aller faire un tour
jean est difficilement et faire un tour
à rambouillet un ca de ce papa est
surtout que c'est quand même pareil la
dernière étape c'est de la parade faut
pas le faux pas ne faut pas le négliger
faut pas l'oublier mais c'est vrai qu'on
aimait bien voir certaines fois des
images de nos coureurs dans la vallée de
chevreuse passé passé les mêmes
difficultés que celles que l'on peut
rencontrer le dimanche matin donc bien
là ce sera pas ce sera pas le cas
j'espère que c'est pas une rupture parce
que faut pas oublier que il y a aussi
une autre convention avec à essos et le
départ de faim c'est votre départ de
paris-nice qui depuis depuis maintenant
près de dix ans par par des yvelines et
et ce serait bien que cela gère le grill
un ellis et le tour de france voilà donc
qu'il faudrait pas que ce soit une
rupture et que département je pense que
après c'est pareil ça fait quand même
pas mal d'années et donc ben mine de
rien des villes qui peuvent accueillir
un départ d'une épreuve comme le tour de
france paraît peut-être qu'il commence
un peu à tourner en rond et donc on va
essayer de trouver une porte de sortie
ou une petite idée un truc être un petit
peu différent mais on sait qu'on connaît
la différence qu'il ya entre être ville
étape est d'être passage étape bas âge
étape dans les yvelines on part tenant
pas suffisamment souvent sur ce plateau
que l'aller mais divine était et terre
de terre de cyclisme donc là je pense
que au bilan j'allais dire comptable
comptable et financier il ya une une
bonne belle différence sur l'édition
2022 au bout du compte pour les îles ce
qui est étonnant c'est là c'est le côté
totalement secret jusqu à l annonce par
rapport à ce qui était ce qui était de
l'ordre de la rumeur peut-être mais mais
en fait de l'ordre aussi de l'habitude
et surtout aussi de delà de la
compétence du département des yvelines
quel que soit le village choisi la ville
au vide elle choisit pour pour être
ville de départ ça tout ça a toujours
très bien fonctionner sa tour donné une
superbe image avec un public qui est
public est conquis sur les bords sur les
bords des routes des yvelines donc c'est
ce côté ce côté coup de théâtre
effectivement qui est étonnant
après oui désormais il ya aussi cette
fusion des départements et que
l'appareil de la défense arena et dans
le 92 dont 92 78 on a du mal quand même
à s'imaginer que ça sera un seul et même
une seule et même entité départementale
malgré tout donc il ya un certain nombre
peut-être de d'éléments qu'on ne
maîtrise pas la preuve puisque on ne l'a
pas vu venir et que et que et qu'au
final peut-être pas définitive
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas toujours pas
c'est que ça fait maintenant près d'une
dizaine de jours une quinzaine de jours
par l'ansés que d'apprendre dans la
défaite et en effet il n'y a pas
d'explication c'est ça qui est plus
pâle hier par inquiétant mais qui est
bizarre selon ce qu'on a ce qu'on a
appris voilà c'est tout simplement que
c'était prévu comme ça maintenant
puisque le matin même dans l'est dans
les médias on entendait voilà
enfin moi j'écoute la radio le matin et
en y allant j'entendais départ de thoiry
quoi aujourd'hui c'est la 10 et la
diffusion enfin bref on va découvrir le
parcours du de france est la dernière
étape donc voilà c'est pas c'est pas
anodin c'est pas et et surtout va que
derrière y ait pas de vraies raisons
expliquées je veux préciser pour ceux
qui ne savent pas en fait depuis 2016 le
département des yvelines et des
hauts-de-seine ont entamé une stratégie
de rapprochement l'idée effectivement
c'est d'aller vers une fusion qui
finalement s'avère beaucoup plus
difficile puisque c'est freiné par
l'état l'état ne voit pas cette fusion
d'un bon oeil et dent pour le moment on
a créé un établissement public ont dit
inter départementale où les deux
départements ont mis en commun des
compétences et c'est vrai que du côté du
département des yvelines on met en avant
ce rapprochement pour dire ben écoute et
finalement on est une seule et même
entité cette pédiatre que les il veut on
la remonte à s'habiller ce choix peut
être peut-être qu'est ce que vous en
pensez vous jean
pour un mâle balles de deux choses dit
autour de la table est-ce que
on a pas on n'a pas soulevé le problème
aussi dit être un petit peu pour le
financier parce qu'on sait pertinemment
pierre l'a dit tout à l'heure que
prendre prendre un départ du tour de
france ça coûte un petit peu d'argent
donc on sait que ça va partir à la
défense on sait qu'il ya qui a des
intérêts financiers aussi derrière donc
est-ce que c'est pas une question de
choix dans la date puisque lé fixait les
fixes elle est fixée la date on le sait
donc c'est bien ou un problème financier
et pour moi je pense que sa robe je
parle je serai plus là dessus est certes
c'est difficile de prendre de prendre un
départ comme ceux cette étape là qu'est
la dernière c'est difficile mais je
pense qu'à ce problème financier parce
que touahri c'était sept pages trouvées
touahri il a un peu à quoi attrister
président passait quelque chose et pas
avoir des manifestations de d'éléphants
de faits
avérés la traîne à thoiry tout était
bien fait bien ficelé je pense que
symbole financiers vont m'aimer pourquoi
touahri a parlé de faits que nous à
votre avis ouah mais là c'est parce que
oui au fait nous parce que peut-être que
le problème que tu as de quoi il croyait
fermement jusqu'à la fin et peut-être
que ben est ce qui a été mis sur la
table et c'est que moi nous au début de
la semaine
oui parce qu'un corps c'est mon pote
pour officiel
non mais si effectivement il lui en
rétro pédalage quelque part que l'étape
était prévu effectivement à thoiry
peut-être que le maire n'aurait pas tout
intérêt à dévoiler qui a eu un rétro
pédalage et finalement dès le début
c'était une fête new je pense que c'est
plus là on parlait de communication tout
à l'heure là on est dans cette stratégie
dans la communication de ne pas de ne
dévoiler aucune aucune information et
nous voilà dans l'est sont les soieries
communiquer là dessus ou les médias
communiquée sur thoiry et puis ben quand
on aura la surprise mais en effet tout
le monde est d'accord derrière c'est une
possibilité mais ce serait bien juste
que quelqu'un le dise tout simplement
dans l'est
dans les sphères voilà je viens chercher
oui bah oui ça sera un jour tout ceci du
coup sûr le reportage qu'on avait fait
il ya maintenant sept ans en 2017 ou
2018 où on disait passera et non pas
partir à est-ce que vous en souvenez
vous acceptez vous qui aviez fait trop
dangereux devant sauver
la petite
donc pas ses impressions en soit il ne
s'en soient aussi en tout cas c'est
passera il n'y a pas et il n'y a pas de
problème a priori non mais après on ne
parlait dans tous les médias on parle de
cette convention qui disait que c'était
la ville départ on parle bien de ville
départ et là en l'occurrence et bien
c'est une ville alto séquanaise qui
serait de ville départ c'est pas une vie
divine oise dernière question tout
simplement les fans de cyclisme dans les
yvelines où penser qu'ils sont dans quel
état de voix de pas voir justement cette
étape ce départ d'étape des yvelines
scoop on sait que ça ça va ça va les
énerver côté des gentils des mariages
ils ont pas encore réagi ça sera ça sera
le jour j le jour j ou autour du tout
autour du tour quand ils verront qu'ils
verront que finalement la caravane ne
passe pas comme d'habitude aussi près
alexane auprès des fans de cyclisme ont
tous enfin tous vu la présentation du
tour parce que si c'est que si on y va
avoir une réaction épidermique non non
c'est pas parce que franchement fin tu
disais que en effet les les spectateurs
étaient toujours au rendez vous et c'est
partout où passe le tour de toute façon
c'est quand même moi je regarde toute
l'année des épreuves de cyclisme et en
dehors des grands monuments mais le tour
de france c'est la seule étape ça c'est
le
seul la seule compétition où du départ
fictif jusqu'à l'arrivée vous avez tout
le temps des gens au bord de la route à
applaudir les encourager les coureurs il
n'y a pas cent la veille au soir et qui
peuvent être bien sûr donc ça ça cia que
sur le tour de france sur le giro ça
n'existe pas sur la vuelta ce n'est pas
la même chose vous n'avez pas cette
cette même ferveur est en effet le tour
de france il déplace les foules au même
titre que le football
par benoît les yvelinois passer le tour
de france est aussi veulent voir le
départ in 0 à l'aréna pour voir les
coureurs parce que si elle prend je suis
n'est pas très très bon parce que
l'abattage de départ c'est qu'il ya une
vraie proximité avec les avec les
coureurs on peut les approcher vraiment
ben moi je me suis retrouvé au milieu du
peloton a discuté avec un coureur au
départ de
corbeil a 20 ans et
donc c'est vraiment hyper accessible et
puis ensuite sinon s'il veut les voir
ils iront dans le département parce que
de toute façon ils passeront sur le
département on va passer à la prochaine
thématique on va reparler football
l'ancien footballeur habib beye était de
retour dans les yvelines le dimanche 17
octobre désormais coach officiel du red
star il est venu affronter le club de
chant pour 6 au cinquième tour de la
coupe de france et il est reparti avec
une belle victoire 6 à 0 dans ses
valises face au club de troisième
division de district on écoute habib
beye nous parle de son rôle d'entraîneur
je prends beaucoup de plaisir basse et
en même temps je me forme pour ça et je
suis d aventure avec le groupe est le
plus important c'est qu'on avance et
qu'on continue à progresser
depuis sa prise de fonction habib beye
originaire de port marly à un bilan
plutôt correcte avec le red star qui
n'était pas dans une bonne situation en
cinq matches son bilan est de 2
victoires 1 nul et 2 défaites cela ne
sûrement pas l'ancien footballeur du psg
à bernard mendy qui étaient venus
assister au match chambourcy et red star
pour l'instant ce qui démontre c'est pas
mal maintenant faut lui laisser le temps
de pouvoir
de pouvoir s'aguerrir et
en tout cas je suis de tout coeur avec
lui habib beye qui n'a pas encore son
diplôme d'entraîneur il est en train de
le passer sa nomination va obliger le
red star à payer une amende de 3000
euros par match plus de 72000 euros pour
la saison tout de même alors la question
un bon joueur petit devenir un grand
entraîneur je vous rappelle qu'il est
passé par strasbourg loi newcastle il a
été international sénégalais
vous hésitez pierre chevallier non pour
vous vous êtes partagés en fait un petit
duel entre
pour vous aussi rigolo non c'est pas non
c'est pas forcément évident qu'un
bonheur un bon joueur et
la question c'est est-ce qu'un bon
joueur peut devenir un bon entraîneur
exactement merci à y jouer est ce qu'il
peut voilà donc est ce qu'il peut de la
réponse est oui enfin un petit duel
entre vous grégory et yann wehrling
trésorerie je vais remuer ce qu'il veut
effectivement est-ce que c'est forcément
une condition est ce que c'est une
conséquence directe non ça je pense je
pense pas on a plein d'exemples et est
bien dans le monde du football récent
d'entraîneurs qui est ont été ans ancien
très bons joueurs et qui n'ont pas
réussi leur carrière d'entraîneur
maintenant moi ce que je voudrais
ajouter sur habib beye c'est que le
parcours lui qui est intéressant pour
lui c'est qu'avant de devenir entraîneur
il a été joueur voilà il a une carrière
assez riche passé notamment par un club
qui vous tient à coeur
michael sait que il a aussi ce rôle de
consultant donc il étudie le football en
quelque sorte qu'il n'a pas été
entraîneur depuis de nombreuses années
sur les ondes de canal moi je le trouve
très intéressant à chaque fois dans ses
analyses ça prouve qu'il a quand même
une réflexion on va dire intelligente
sur le football qui il arrive à prendre
ce recul est peut-être que ce recul qui
elle a eu un ton consultant va l'aider
dans sa future carrière d'entraîneur
c'est vrai que depuis qu'il arrivait au
red star ce qui se dit ce qui filtre du
vestiaire c'est qu'il est voilà il fait
l'unanimité au sein de son vestiaire il
a pris le red star voulait rappeler
juste après le licenciement de vincent
bordot un moment où le red star était
relégable aujourd'hui le red star et 12e
de national donc c'est c'est une bonne
performance pour lui mieux en tout cas
pour le nom il ya du mieux de nation moi
en tout cas par rapport au cac habib
beye je ne fais pas de souci maintenant
c'est vrai que je me suis tiré une balle
dans le pied oui bien évidemment qu'un
bon joueur peut devenir un bon
entraîneur est ce que c est ce que c'est
une conséquence non écoute attention et
il fallait écouter jeudi dernier donc la
réponse est oui tout simplement il n'y a
rien à dire
rien à ajouter c'est vrai que un bon un
joueur peut devenir un bon entraîneur
maintenant c'est vrai que nous habib
beye on ne connaît quand même assez peu
en effet avec ses analyses aujourd'hui
au cfc mais à part d' à part ça pour
nous c'était un joueur un peu papa de
yarakh d'exotique mais parce que oui il
a joué il a joué à marseille il a maigri
capitaine de l'om
le sénégal mais effectivement c'est pas
le joueur inconnu c'est pas le joueur le
plus le plus connu en france mais voilà
et qui vit presque plus connu est donc
conscient quand j'entends bien cher
c'est vrai est donc maintenant à lui de
faire ses preuves à lui prendre son
temps je pense qu il le fait de manière
assez intelligente justement de
d'arrivée par la nationale est
certainement qu il à l'envi de grimper
les échelons je pense que ce sera
peut-être entre guillemets plus facile
pour lui dans ce sens là que que pour
zinédine zidane par exemple qui est
arrivé directement real madrid et avec
des difficultés et des très belles
réussites
trois livres des champions
d'affilée voilà c'est un léger détail et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui il n'attend
qu'une chose c'est de voir didier
deschamps dire bon j'en ai marre de la
l'équipe de france est donc bien ce sera
peut-être le suivant faut pas l'oublier
oublier c'est fini il est justement
aussi dans cette génération de joueurs
qui vont en qui ont des dd pour certains
des réussites en tant qu'entraîneur
c'est un peu un peu le même le même
noyau donc voilà les sons laissons-les
son temps ont par contre nous
l'avantagent ce qu'on va pouvoir
surveiller et il se met en veille dessus
pour pourvoir les résultats continuent
de s'améliorer pour pour le red star et
puis mais je pense que ce n'est qu'une
étape omis genre qui vous a convaincu
grégory yann vous étiez partager
et mal compris mais non mais
tout à fait tout a été dit est sûr qu'un
bon joueur pour devenir mon entraîneur
mais c'est pas systématique ça c'est sûr
dans vos déchets ces sept canadiens
toutes les disciplines dans tout et
c'est valable pour toutes les
disciplines la seule chose c'est que
lorsqu'on a été un bon joueur on a on a
quand même on a quand même l'expérience
du terrain et on sait que quatre dont
passe entraîneur on sait le qu'on parle
quand on a été sportif comme dans la
pratique et la discipline c'est une des
cordes à l'arc qu'on peut avoir
supplémentaires à quelqu'un qui a appris
le job enfin le sport sur les bouquins
parce que voilà c'est la seule qui a
fait c'est là la seule etc est immense
pour moi parce que lorsqu'on sait de
quoi on parle on ne le fait plus avec
les tripes et avec le coeur que
lorsqu'on a appris sur des bouquets donc
c'est que c'est une quête pour moi une
grande indifférence de et une grande
qualité d'un entraîneur donc pour ça
effectivement je sais tout ce qu'on peut
lui souhaiter et le fait contrairement
il ya ne le disais à des entraîneurs
comme zidane ou il arrive directement
dans un grand club européen avec trois
coupes d'europe d'affilée après il faut
pas oublier qu'il est passé par les
équipes b gsi du real madrid oui tout à
fait de fait l'homme a fait il était
déjà dans un bien sûr le but est bien
sûr il était déjà il a fait des classes
haut de gamme quand même
alors que bay alors que babe on démarre
démarre au red star qui n'est pas un
grand club et il fait ses armes mais un
club assez suivi comme danser suis parce
que c'est connu c'est connu le red star
c'est un châssis par exemple y avoir
environ 60 70 supporters du red star par
exemple qui se sont déplacés pour
rejoindre habib beye son absence causé
c'est un club en région parisienne à qui
et qui a une histoire et est qui et qui
est qui et qui est en haut de la fiche
pas au niveau sportif mais au niveau et
regarder entre huy ha vu est tout à fait
donc c'est bien il commence par là et
c'est qu'on peut lui souhaiter 15,8 ce
soit un tremplin pour lui et qui
prennent une équipe professionnelle il a
surtout toute la légitimité pour pouvoir
s'adresser à des joueurs de niveau
nation c'est aussi un parti ça plutôt
convaincu par marianne sur la
formulation de la question
c'est sûr peut devenir oui mais je
viendrai quand même au secours de grève
dans dix ans que et
de ska de ski a complété janot sur la
sur la connaissance et la compétence ça
fait peut-être 20 ans 25 ans qui vit
dans le football
la mise en lumière qu'il a en ce moment
comme consultant chez chez nos éminents
confrères est
essentiel aussi sur le sur le langage et
sur la transmission de l'expérience
parce que je le trouve bon moi je le
trouve bon sur ces commentaires je
trouve bon sur ses interventions au cfc
ce qui n'est pas le cas de tous et des
anciens des anciens sportifs de haut
niveau dans leur est dit pinet
respectives et vous prenez l'exemple du
rugby par exemple là je pense que celle
inverse qui est vrai c'est à dire que
c'est un quelqu'un qui n'a pas joué au
rugby à mon avis aura du mal à devenir
un bon entraîneur de rugby qu'est ce qui
est mieux que le football je sais pas si
c'est vrai aussi est transposable au
football mais mais en tout cas il a il à
cette belle île à 7,7 légitimité des
grands clubs des grandes compétitions
parce que lille a aussi quelques
sélections internationales avec le
sénégal est donc est donc cette
légitimité et cette crédibilité qui
devrait lui faire passer quelques cap
qu'il commence en bas de l'échelle en
national enfin quand je dis en bas de
l'échelle c'est pas péjoratif
nationale et puis qu'il puisse viser
plus grand dans certains viennent club
oui effectivement au bas de l'échelle
mais avec on le disait quand même une
médiatisation le red star ça reste un
club parisien dont on espère peut être
un jour les voir en ligue 1 alors ça ça
reste difficile mais il ya toujours ce
rêve de voir un deuxième club parisien
le lien et le red star à un moment donné
c'était peut-être le principal candidat
pour aller en ligne il y aura quand même
une médiatisation autour de lui donc à
lui aussi de gérer la pression parce
qu'il sera au niveau national mais il
sera scruté clairement clairement et
paris fc aussi après clairement pas en
région parisienne les parias section des
tout-petits que des tout petits poucet
qui ont eu des histoires par exemple en
coupe de france et qui sont protégés
ligue 2 elien 10 pour clermont on le
disait est ce que c'est bien également
qu'il soit avec soin sur un petit club
parce qu'on pense par exemple à thierry
henry raïs et comme on peut dire cramer
quand même assez rapidement en étant à
monaco en 2018 il a eu un bilan de 4
victoires 5 nuls 11 défaites il est
ensuite parti à l'impact de montréal et
la huent un bilan de 9 victoires 4 nuls
16 défaites
aujourd'hui plus grand monde n'en veut
il est adjoint finalement avec l'équipe
de belgique c'est ça un exemple parlant
qu'il ne faut pas suivre je voulais pas
forcément
tout à l'heure mais effectivement
thierry henry du grand joueur qu'il a
été on voit toute la difficulté qu'il a
eu il ya certes un grand joueur un qui
en devenant entraîneur son passé aussi
par des petites divisions c'est comme ça
ils ont réussi tout à l'heure c'est vrai
qu'on cité l'exemple de zidane zidane il
a eu la chance aussi je pense parce que
faut pas oublier qu avec la castilla
donc c'est l'équipe b du real madrid il
n'a pas forcément eu de très bons
résultats aussi lui a profité aussi de
son aura il allie north alors c'est pas
le joueur le plus expansif le plus
communicatif zidane mais forcément le
le joueur qui a gagné une coupe du monde
qui a fait une finale aussi qui a bola
une légitimité qui est deux buts en
finale alain dumont deux buts deux buts
en finale de coupe du monde dans un
vestiaire où y'avait cristiano ronaldo
il arrivé avec sa légitimité et je pense
que les joueurs du real il avait quand
même une capacité à entraîner les
joueurs du real ont suivi dans cet
exemple là thierry henry c'est vrai
qu'il s'est retrouvé dans des projets
aussi qu'ils étaient un peu qui est un
peu compliqué les vingt pays n'arrive à
monaco suisse était compliqué là restait
peut-être peut-être compliqué mais
didier deschamps je n'ai pas beaucoup
pas beaucoup plus facile et il a payé
d'une finale des champions que je
comprends les des exemples les plus
probants et mais peut-être les meilleurs
joueurs du monde mais pas pas si loin de
chez nous ça dépend de la personnalité
de l'ancien joueur grands et moins
grands
laurent fournier à poissy c'est aussi
c'est aussi l'expérience a
plus l'habitude d'être l'un des gros
clubs plutôt de voir que des petits et
donc ça dépend ça dépend du contexte et
ça dépend de la personnalité du joueur
et de son expérience globale et puis
savoir aussi si la s'il a la grinta et
lila et le charisme pour entraîner des
groupes que ce soit un groupe d'amateurs
ou aux professions de contrat on voit
qu'il ya des entraîneurs aussi qu'ils
réussissent sans avoir une énorme
expérience de joueur professionnel je
pense à rudi garcia qui avait quand même
une carrière d'entraîneur est encore
plus josé mourinho si on prend un
exemple très connu lui n'a même pas été
footballeur professionnel
il a été même traducteur au fc barcelone
et ça ne l'a pas empêché de devenir
l'entraîneur qu'on le connaît
aujourd'hui on connaît aujourd'hui même
si maintenant elle est plus sur une
pente descendante mais il a quand même
gagné une ligue des champions josé
mourinho ce n'est pas rien n'était sur
des pochettes de jeux vidéo si à une
époque c'est vrai dans la question vous
le voyez aller où habib beye peut-être
après le red star ce que vous avez déjà
une idée est ce que vous voyez en
traînant france à l'étranger peut-être
pas encore pourquoi selon vous pourquoi
pas mais ça c'est l'avenir qui le dira
est-ce que ça est-ce que cela soit à son
poste ce n'était même pas dans la série
donc s'il y arrive et il sait pour moi
ce sera peut-être un play et peut-être
qu'il va se planter mais s'il y arrive
le vois bien pourquoi pas en france mais
en angleterre parce que là aussi aussi
passé par newcastle aston villa donc
c'est aussi un milieu cette première
league qui connaît bien donc pourquoi
pas l'avenir mais d'abord qu'il
réussisse à s'imposer au niveau national
on va l'encourager à passer des tours en
coupe de france donc c'est
qu'il ya un loup en coupe de france
en tout cas on souhaite bon courage
habib beye pour la suite de sa carrière
d'entraîneur on va maintenant parler
tennis est une très bonne nouvelle pour
le tennis yvelinois arthur wint naish le
saint germanois vient d'être sélectionné
pour participer à la coupe davis qui se
déroulera du 25 novembre au 5 décembre
en autriche puis en espagne sébastien
grosjean le capitaine a décidé de lui
faire confiance arthur rinderknecht est
l'une des plus belles progressions du
tennis français ces derniers mois il
pointe actuellement à la 65e place
mondiale la question sur ce thème est ce
que c'est une surprise oui ou non
oui pour vous yann vous êtes partagés
pierre mais non non pour vous 3 non et
ah oui genre pourquoi n'ont même pas
c'est pas une surprise mais c'est pas
une surprise dans la mesure dans la
mesure où il passe de la 7e à la 63e 65e
68e peut-être 63e prochaines semaines
vous dire qu'ils se sont produits
aujourd'hui alors aussi de la télé j'ai
regardé aujourd'hui 65e c'est vrai je
devais une virulente a mis à jour
un peu pour moi passée la 7ème à la 5ème
cpc pas une surprise c'est une surprise
et abuse d'autant plus qui prend la
place de gaël monfils antonio mais je
viens pas de place réservée simplement
gaël monfils sort de l'équipe et lui
rentre bon après on ne peut pas on peut
parler aussi de passation un petit peu
de 2,2 de pouvoir de génération qui fait
que ben peut-être un petit peu sur le
déclin et lui il en plaine en place à
l'aise mais pour moi non non ce n'est
pas un c'est pas une surprise c'est par
rapport à ses performances actuelles et
sa fulgurante progression dans le
classement
jarrier vous êtes contre tout le monde
aujourd'hui seul contre tous
ben oui surprise parce que en effet on a
quand même l'habitude d'avoir les
élections et sortir gaël monfils qui est
aujourd'hui 25e au classement atp par le
65e il ya quand même un gros décalage
après bien sûr qu'il y en a une qui a
comme tu disais un qui est plutôt en
phase descendante et l'otan en face en
phase d'ascension mais ouais on s'y
attendait pas attention il est
sélectionné il a dit qu'il était
vraiment pas sûr de jouer il est là dans
l'équipement pas là il et il n'est pas
sûr de jouer donc du coup c'est
peut-être aussi pour lui donner de
l'expérience parce que s'il continue de
progresser encore je suis anglais
prochaines années il deviendra
certainement titulaire indiscutable
voilà je pense qu'il ya aussi une
stratégie plus plus long terme et aussi
que dire maintenant 11 ans à dire il
voulait faire un mélange entre jeunes
joueurs et des joueurs expérimentés avec
richard gasquet notamment qu' avec la
remporter cette coupe davis et gaël
monfils n'était pas chaud pour jouer la
coupe davis au mois de décembre parce
que il va avoir un gros mois de janvier
très important
où il doit aller chercher des points
pour garder ces essais se sont quasiment
atp donc voilà les raisons sont entre
guillemets politique et statistiques
derrière voilà il ya il ya plusieurs
éléments qui mis ensemble ont fait cette
sélection pour pour notre église noire
parce que sinon les japonais non mais
l'aspect le jour un pas peut-être pas
c'est intéressant je pense qu'un joueur
comme arthur rinderknecht qui fait son
entrée en équipe de france de coupe
davis qui ne jouent pas ne va pas faire
de vagues et imaginons qu'un gaël
monfils viennent et ne joue pas je pense
qu'il y aurait un peu plus de deuil
maintenant moi je pense que ce n'est pas
une surprise la surprise c'est plutôt
son ascension fulgurante dont on a
débattu ici en plateau maintenant de le
voir à cette 65ème place mondiale il
fait de supers résultats 2e tour à us
open 1er tour à wimbledon voilà je veux
dire pour le joueur au parcours qu'il a
eus je parle de supers résultats c'est
pas des landes résultat mais au vu du
parcours qu'il a eue
voilà ça c'est mérité il est pro que
depuis 2003 hawks et et ensuite ce que
ce que vous disiez sur tout à l'heure ce
que vous avez dit sur le fait de
mélanger des jeunes joueurs des joueurs
un peu plus expérimenté ce que ce qui
apporte aussi d'intéressants arthur et
9,9 dans cette équipe de france et qu'il
a un parcours très atypique il a été sur
le circuit à partir de 25 ans il a il a
fait ses études aux états unis il est
venu finalement assez tard par rapport à
voilà si on prend la sélection herbert
gasquet mahut voilà il ya du jeune mais
aussi du joueur qui qui est là depuis
voilà qui fédérer qui fait la une des
médias depuis de nombreuses années et je
trouve qu'il apporte aussi ce côté
intéressant d'avoir un profil différent
sein de cette équipe d'offrir un vent de
fraîcheur peut être aussi de serre
chevallier a cessé les deux les deux
raisons pour lesquelles il n'y a pas de
surprise la première c'est qu'on parle
suffisamment ici depuis longtemps depuis
ses premiers pour moi c'est tout premier
tournoi
celles qui ne le connais pas recours
atypique
mais comme ses mensurations et son
gabarit 1 m 96 voilà donc ces il fait
partie il fait partie justement de ces
de ses standards un peu physique qui
sont qui sont assez lourds parce que si
on compare par exemple à dschang dans
les années 80 90 on est on est aux
antipodes de ça mais si les générations
qui arrivent sont grandes et costaud et
bien bâti
tels des pingouins de pierre comme ça et
la deuxième raison c'est ça c'est
justement cette alchimie place aux
jeunes on garde quand même de
l'expérience et on garde quand même des
vieux briscards parce que parce qu'on
peut pas tout tout refaire d'un seul
coup de dés mais en tout cas c'est une
vraie chance qui lui est donnée qu'il
joue qu'il joue pas ça reste une
sélection il arrive en coupe davis et ça
c'est effectivement un vent de fraîcheur
qui fait du bien aux en france et dans
les yvelines les quarts de finale en
plus à l'atp d'anvers un bon éliminé
parade italien et yannick lieners
peut-être mais attia il en a pas et n'a
pas souffert mais voilà il fait des bons
résultats il y le il est où il est dit
aussi qu'ils qui parce qu'elles soient
parcours universitaire aux états unis il
a fait beaucoup de compétitions par
équipe et c'est vraiment un format qui
l'a qu'il affectionne à la base c'est
plus un joueur de double en fait
arthurienne neige plutôt qu'un joueur de
simple finalement six ans hormis en
simple qu'en double il est aux alentours
de la 60e place saint-vaast ou b en
double mais pourquoi pas le voir sur du
double aussi dans dans les prochaines
années un solo ou bien roland garros
était en doublon l'année suivi avec
florian la cavalcade qui est également
qui sort de plaisir qui sort de plaisir
vous le voyez aller jusqu'où alors que
renault knecht ce sera ma dernière
question sur cette thématique est ce que
vous pensez qui peut s'installer
durablement dans cette équipe de france
pierre chevallier oui oui c'est
évidemment ce qu'on lui souhaite mais
mais vu le
gris clair il va voir la pression sur
l'iran jeudi il faut qu'il faut qu'ils
apprennent même si les métiers est
arrivé tard sur le circuit professionnel
c'est le moment lui donner ses chances
là et c'est cette ce coup de projecteur
monumentale que représente la coupe
davis surtout s'il la joue si les s'il
est vraiment sur le terrain mais en tout
cas c'est
c'est à tous bouts qui a prouvé que même
en arrivant en dehors des sentiers
battus ils pouvaient ils étaient
capables de performer la gagner 400 440
places et est ce qu'on peut lui
souhaiter c'est un top 50 c'est à dire
de continuer aussi après la progression
plus pour l'instant il est sûrement trop
tôt pour le dire mais en tout cas c'est
c'est une jeune pépite est une belle
promesse ce qui est sûr c'est que
aujourd'hui le tennis français est quand
même dans une période très compliquée et
d'avoir un d'avoir un arthur comme ça
qu'ils qui brille ben ça fait du bien
voilà parce que un joueur qui fait
également beaucoup de tournois et chaque
semaine quasiment ont toutes les deux
semaines il fait un tournoi ils se
déplacent partout ce n'est pas le cas de
forcément tous les joueurs il faut faire
rentrer des sous
il a rêvé oui en effet ça m a gagné des
points en jouant partout mais c'est
aussi une manière de enfin voila quand
on est pro c'est enfin fo fo en vivre
quoi donc et et leurs structures basse
et équiper tous les entraîneurs les
préparateurs il est lé tout ce qui est
ma sage tout là tout l'accompagnement
donc et il fait lui-même son programme
et il négocie avec ses sponsors pour
l'instant c'est soucieux 28e
il est encore et là encore pas amateur
mais pas loin de ça que je pense après
je suis pas dans la tête de d'arthur
hiller neige c'est que il aura aucune
pression je pense pas qu'ils
s'imaginaient alors c'était son objectif
quand on avait discuté avec lui vous
l'aviez interviewé d'aller dans ce top
100 son objectif a été rempli maintenant
j'ai envie de dire c'est que du bonus et
je pense pas alors je suis pas dans sa
tête mais finalement peut-être qu'il
pourra jouer aussi sans pression et ça
c'est aussi un plus pour lui on espère
le voir en tout cas sur sur les courts
de tennis les matches de poule de la
france joueront dès le 25 novembre à
innsbruck en autriche les bleus
rencontreront la grande-bretagne et la
république tchèque on passe maintenant
notre page débats
on va maintenant passer à votre envolé à
grégory le moment le plus incroyable de
ceux ci ont parlé sport de quoi allez
vous nous parlez grégory je vous propose
déjà de prendre des nouvelles de huy de
victor webb anyama voilà j'étais
tellement concentré sur son nom que
c'est vraiment les noms les plus simples
octobre web anyama notre pépite du
basket qui était la forme et à l'entente
le chesnay versailles qui a fait un
grand saut puisqu'il est passé de
nanterre au champion de france en titre
l'asvel et on l'espère peut-être un saut
aussi en nba en 2023 avec la draft
regardez ces images on le reconnaît
facilement avec ses deux maîtresses 19
le longiligne ailier de 17 ans a joué 10
minutes dans ce match remporté 94 à 80
face à châlons-reims il y a inscrit
trois points à dun qu un lancer-franc
également pour arthur rinderknecht on va
voir le lancer return gagner ma
vie victor wemba niamana je me perds
voilà c'est ça on va le voir inscrire
bon le lancer franc ça y est on va le
voir inscrire sur lancer-franc donkey et
venez juste d'inscrire deux points juste
avant il a obtenu l'annoncé prend pour
une faute voilà c'est inscrit et il est
finalement assez simple de suivre cette
année les performances de victor web
bannières là oui ça a été assez chanceux
se lancer franc puisque il en veut on
peut le suivre assez facilement puisque
depuis cette année il y à la lnb td
c'est une plateforme en ligne gratuite
qui est proposé par la ligue nationale
de basket qui permet de voir tous les
matches de cette
betclic élite c'est le nom qu'on donne
au premier championnat la première
division de basket en france alors
gratuit vous allez me dire c'est bien
peut-être on peut voir tous les to les
voilà tous les matches mais il faut dire
que les moyens de production sont
minimes des caméras tourelles
automatiques qui donne l'impression de
regarder un vieux jeux vidéo des joueurs
qui sont parfois hors champ vous le
voyez là le ballon est caché par par
l'habillage alors de notre chaîne mais
aussi par l'habillage est bien de du
site de là
b les joueurs sont en revanche en bref
on aura peut-être de quoi satisfaire les
fans puristes de basket qui seront
contents de voir leur club et bien
n'importe quelle journée mais c'est
difficile en revanche de fidéliser un
public parce que la qualité n'est pas au
rendez vous alors pourquoi cette
situation le championnat de france a
trouvé cette parade car aucun diffuseur
n'a mis d'argent sur la table pour
empocher a les droits du basket français
il est a déjà loin le temps où 10
millions d'euros été mis sur la table
pour une saison de basket côté aux
reliques ces mêmes problèmes
championnats d'europe il n'ya pas
diffuseur aujourd'hui en france avec
pourtant des clubs comme l'asvel et
monaco qui sont plutôt séduisant sur le
papier il faut se connecter sur une
plate forme cette fois ci payant pour
assister aux rencontres alors la
situation du basket rats devant le
médaillé d'argent pour les hommes et de
bronze aux jo elle n'est pas un cas
isolé hormis le football le rugby les
sports mécaniques on peut y ajouter un
peu de cyclisme un peu de tennis
également les autres sports sont
énormément ont énormément de difficultés
à trouver une exposition en france et
surtout à capitaliser leurs droits le
trio basket handball volley le fameux
bhv cinq médailles aux jo dont trois en
or en est le parfait exemple on en
termine avec le basket par exemple un
côté sélection hormis les coupes
d'europe masculine aucun diffuseur ne
s'est positionné aujourd'hui pour les
autres rencontres des bleus que ce soit
pour les hommes et les femmes dans le
bhv c'est finalement le handball qui
s'en sort le mieux des sélections
exposés heureusement vous me direz après
deux médailles d'or les coupes d'europe
aussi à des clubs sont diffusées deux
médailles d'or aux jo en bien sûr pour
le handball français hommes et femmes
allaient droit pour le championnat de
france de handball s'élève à 4 millions
d'euros par saison laly qui mollit et
starling c'est le championnat de d1
masculine qui est parmi les meilleurs
d'europe 1 on dit dans le milieu c'est
un peu la première league du handball à
la première league le championnat bien
sûr d'angleterre de football mais encore
là on peut trouver du négatif même si le
handball est diffusée en france il ya
moins de matches de championnat qui sont
proposés par journée seulement 3 un seul
côté féminin le reste est à voir aussi
sur une plateforme gratuite qui a été
mise en place par la ligue nationale de
handball enfin le volet c'est le parent
pauvre de ce bhv malgré une médaille
d'or magnifique obtenus aux jo comme le
basket les matches de championnat sont
visés gratuitement sur une plateforme
lnv tv ligue nationale de volley
télévision sauf une affiche qui est
payant par journée est les playoffs
seront également payant à cette saison
pire encore pour voir les compétitions
internationales et bien c'est impossible
aujourd'hui elles n'ont pas trouvé
preneur impossible donc de suivre les
aventures la suite des aventures de la
bande à ngapeth qui nous a émerveillés
cet été bref vous l'avez compris c'est
un peu le grand bazar à cette question
des droits télé dans le monde du bhv ce
basket handball volley malgré des
résultats exceptionnels ces sports sont
boudés par les grands diffuseurs je
trouve ça regrettable bhv a été mis sur
un piédestal cet été et l'engouement
était tous rendez vous pour ces
disciplines qui ont permis en quelque
sorte à l'équipe de france à la
sélection france aux jo de se sauver
parce que jusqu'à présent jusqu'au
moment de ses médailles en sports
collectifs les légions était bien maigre
1 33 médailles a collecté au final par
la délégation française laissait aurait
pu être transformé il n'en a pas été
ainsi après des jo réussi et j'ai bien
peur que ces sports tombe retombe dans
l'oubli des médailles d'or qui nous ont
permis de passer devant l'italie
notamment tableau des médailles à l'afp
bien sûr je tiens à signaler grégory
bien jouer michael alors tout simplement
que ce que vous pensez de ce coup de
gueule de grégory pierre chevallier ce
que ça vous surprend qu'est ce que vous
en pensez non pas tellement surpris
parce qu'on sait tous que 15 corps pour
perdurer a besoin de médiatisation a
besoin de mise en avant mais gégé 2 on
va dire deux arguments sont pas
forcément des arguments contre l'essai
de dire que désormais vu tous les sports
qui lie à pratiquer à bas plus haut n'y
ait plus ou moins haut niveau en france
il ya embouteillage en fait en gros sur
toutes les chaînes de télé on a la
chance maman d'avoir des bouquets des
bouquets payants et des chaînes des
chaînes qui sont maintenant partout
partout et qui peuvent proposer un petit
peu de un petit peu d'exposition mais il
n'y a pas de place pour tout le monde et
je dirai juste pour tempérer que le
succès post chiot il est dans les salles
qui je pense je pense et j'espère vont
pas forcément connaître toutes les tous
les tous les chiffres des lits des
licenciés mais que au moins une balle ça
ça reprend et ça continue volley volley
ç'a toujours été un petit peu difficile
mais mes os mais au moins que qu'on ait
eue qu'on ait eu un effet un effet
retard sur la prise de licence
pour le basket pour le basket derrière
la nba derrière les américains n'y a pas
grand-chose qui perdu entendre en france
depuis depuis assez longtemps peut-être
avec l'épaule et l'épopée de limoges et
l'épopée de de la n'sele en son temps
mais mais c'est à peu près tout pour
revenir à des sports que je connais un
petit peu mieux je dis est maintenant on
a une médiatisation du rugby avec avec
des matches en prime time il ya du
spectacle c'est ça aussi c'est qu'il ya
du spectacle régulièrement même si à
force de de broadcast et toutes les
semaines il ya déjà des affiches qui
sont un petit peu moins alléchante et on
s'ennuie un petit peu plus mais en tout
cas oui besoin médiatisation des
licenciés qui viennent après ça ça
peut-être exploser mais en tout cas
je pense pas qu'il retombe dans l'oubli
pour pour autant alors les trois sports
peut-être si on prend tous les trois
têtes en équipe et il va retomber dans
l'oubli les mais en tout cas on a eu
tellement on a tellement vibrer et cd
sport qui sont finalement tellement
tellement dans le paysage français que
que qu'on peut les soutenir déjà espérer
que les licenciés y soit est ce que ça
vous donne envie vous de regarder ses
matchs sur sur internet et donc en oui
ç'a toujours été
basket basket français un peu moins et
volets le volet wii et c'est ce qui me
fait dire d'ailleurs aussi c'est que
désormais je pense que
jeannot les mêmes types de propositions
même dans le sport amateur maintenant on
a des propositions de d'applications
d'applications vidéo qui permettent aux
amateurs de prendre leur match et même
de rediffuser les plus belles actions
les plus belles actions sur le sur du
match sur une page facebook où il compte
instagram et et de paille et de pouvoir
justement avoir une espèce de diffusion
en live qui est aussi possible sur
certaines applications le basket on a
quand même l'impression que c'est une
diffusion un peu amateur alors pourquoi
le joueur je suis pas perdre vos
fessionnels en football la ligue 1 pour
préparez vous la ligue des champions
mais n'hésitez pas à aller sur lnb tv on
a vraiment l'impression de regarder un
vieux jeu vidéo on s'est fait la
réflexion tout à l'heure des années 2000
les joueurs la caméra n'arrive même pas
à les suivre il est fait maintenant
c'est là juste là le ballon ils voient
plus la mer il ya carrément l'action
même qui n'est même plus suivie par la
rencontre alors sur celle sur secteur
reconnaît que notre bordeaux mascara un
petit peu le mais le voilà on n'y a pas
de bandeau et l'action ne la voit pas le
ballon et tout en bas après ce qu'il
faut dire aussi c'est que sur la bête
clic élite il ya des clubs qui ont
investi dans des moyens de production
quasiment professionnel où il ya des
ralentis il ya des plans larges mais
l'asvel qui est pourtant le champion en
titre de l'un des berceaux de france et
l'un des meilleurs clubs de france 1
présidée par tony parker n'a pas fait ce
choix est resté sur ses tourelles
automatiques genre ça ça vous choque
question qu'est ce que vous en pensez ça
vous choque oui ça me choque parce que
ce sont des disciplines qui mériterait
d'être médiatisé
maintenant on aborde souvent sur son
plateau ce sujet-là des sports
médiatique médiatisé mise à part quand
on regarde bien mise à part le football
qui est hyper médiatisé il rugby
également le rugby de plus en plus c'est
pas encore non plus
c'est pas comparable l'entrée pour
l'après vous avez vous avez le cyclisme
la qui mise à part le tour de france et
peut-être le paris roubaix après ap
après c'est terminé et malheureusement
malheureusement c'est quoi ces c
les investisseurs qui choisissent les
sports qui leur apporteront le plus con
finalement donc malheureusement ces
disciplines là alors que sportivement
elles sont en haut de la fiche
malheureusement ne sont pas médiatisés à
leur juste valeur sportive mais c'est
plus du sport là c'est pas une question
de sport c'est ça le problème et on le
sait ce sera toujours comme ça
malheureusement ce sera toujours comme
ça 8 mondial je vois les noirs c'est
regrettable pour les supporters non mais
je veux bien sûr mais quand je vois les
images les images dont grégory parler de
du basket mais j'ai tendance à dire
c'est mieux que rien parce que ça permet
quand même mine de rien de pouvoir
suivre son équipe
fétiche quoi donc c'est sûr que c'est
pas c'est pas génial c'est pas une bonne
qualité les joueurs regardez là au petit
écrin on les distingue tout juste le
radier petit paquebot les diamants le
distingue parce que lille ait pu y met
une tête à tout le monde quoi de tête
oui les passagers parce qu'on le sait
mais sinon les autres on est 10eme beau
dire et malheurs mais quelque part voilà
je le dis mais c'est mieux que rien
alors voilà on passe de kane 10 millions
d'euros qui est émis par saison par le
groupe haïti cinq y diffuser les matchs
sur rmc sport a rien aujourd'hui il n'y
a pas eu d'accord avec un diffuseur on
parlait peut-être de l'équipe qui
diffusait l'année dernière les matches
on parlait de canal aussi mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya une pierre disait quelque
chose d'intéressant tout à l'heure sur
il manque de ça manque de place il
manque de créneaux et moi je suis pas du
tout d'accord
on va donner à voir et parce qu'on
approche de la fin de cette émission
comique nous et bien sûr que y'en a des
crédits ou sauf que le problème qu'il ya
c'est que la france prend le football
prend trop de place je suis désolé
l'équipe vous l'avais dit à diffuser du
basket à diffuser du hand aujourd'hui
ils ont la ligne 2 et ben ali de monts
en a rien à en forme non mais je
suis désolé il ya trop de foot il ya
trop de football donc montré nous en
montrer nous autre chose voilà
montrez-nous du horn montrez-nous du
basket montrer ou du volet est là oui on
va prendre plaisir suis désolé -
l'équipe diffuse un match de volleyball
féminin ou masculin je regarde parce que
oui bien j'aime ce sport
particulièrement et je le trouve hyper
spectaculaire et très télévisuel mais
voilà je trouve que c'est dommage il se
spécialise pas assez l'équipe quand ils
mettent du biathlon c'est génial et le
biathlon s'est pourtant pas un sport
d'un million téléspectateurs et ça fait
plus d'un million de téléspectateurs de
juste dire voilà en plus on parle des
championnats du manque de place de ces
sports en championnat et le problème se
pose aussi pour les équipes de france je
le disais puisqu'aujourd'hui les équipes
de france masculines féminines en dehors
de la coupe d'europe au basket pas
diffuseur et le volet aujourd'hui y'a
aucun diffuseur pour audi
la suite des aventures là où sur le
volet c'est vrai que quand on passe de
l'intensité d'un match entre deux
équipes nationales à des matches de
clubs oui on voit un peu comme au rugby
on voit qu'il ya une baisse de il ya une
baisse mais au football mais mon lien je
suis désolé il ya des matches où on se
fait chier quoi
cartons carton jaune jene déjà je suis
désolé yann c'est déjà
dans les heurts
je suis à la place pour tout le monde
c'est du coup déjà à la fin de cette
émission on va terminer par un grand
merci à romain russe finit le
réalisateur qui dans les loges juste
derrière on réagit pardon dans les loges
en régie voulait dire aux régies voilà
un petit mot peut-être tour cette table
pour maryse fini
grégory un grand réalisateur mais voilà
il nous quitte après gisèle d'alléger
les jours c'était du chiqué pour finir
par revenir dans mon premier mon premier
reportage avec vous donc ouais c'est
vrai que ça va faire bizarre depuis le
voir quand on arrivera quand on arrivera
sur le plateau sera jamais très loin
jean peut-être un petit mot
s'il a eu le choix
mais il faut bien sûr il n'est pas mort
il est juste au régime encore merci à
marc espi ni alors on va terminer comme
des petites par une citation aujourd'hui
on termine par une citation du pilote de
formule 1 lewis hamilton s'est un peu
oui le roman russe finit de la formule 1
ma devise et nous gagnons et nous
perdons ensemble je pense que cela
s'applique à la fois mes fans ma famille
et mon équipe je vous laisse méditer sur
cette phrase à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui